- Hey, legal eagles, you hear a lot
about case briefs in law school.
What is a case brief?
Why do people do them?
And why do students
hate them so damn much?
What can you do to get the benefits
without the hassle of case briefs?
Well, today we're answering
all of those questions,
and by the end of the video,
you'll know exactly what
goes into a case brief
and how to supercharge them.
So stick around.
(upbeat music)
Before we get into the case brief,
we need to talk about law
school in general for a second.
Law school is taught
using the Case Method,
or the inductive approach
of learning the law
through cases that have already,
supposedly, applied the law.
So for the sake of class discussion,
professors assign
several cases for reading
before students get to class.
That can result in having to
read dozens of cases a night
and potentially hundreds
of pages worth of cases.
So let's start with what is a case
in the law school context?
I know this might seem simplistic,
but stick with me just for a second.
In law school, when you read a case,
what you're really reading
is an appellate opinion.
That is, after the trial or
judgment in the court below,
one of the parties claims
that the trial court was wrong
and appeals the decision
to the court of appeals.
The factual record is set.
You can't change it, you can't
call additional witnesses,
there's no additional evidence.
The parties write legal briefs
and after weighing the
briefs of both sides,
the appellate court will
then issue a written opinion.
Usually that's on a narrow issue of law.
In theory, the appellate court summaries
the important facts of the case,
but not necessarily always,
and in theory, they write
only as much analysis
as is necessary to adjudicate the appeal.
But this is almost never the case.
The appellate opinions
are almost always longer
than they need to be,
sometimes to provide context
and sometimes because judges just
like to hear themselves talk.
So, in law school, a case brief
is a summary of a particular
appellate opinion.
Standard advice says that your
case brief should look like this.
It should start with the case citation.
You should have the name of both parties,
which is usually something
like Jones versus Smith.
It should include the publisher
of the particular case,
the reporter that the
case can be found in.
The court that issued the decision,
the year that the opinion was published.
The procedural posture of the case,
meaning how it got to the court of appeal
the history of the case, a
discussion of where it came from.
The Statement of Facts, the
narrative story of the case.
The issues that were decided on appeal.
The arguments on either side.
The policy implications
of the different ways
that the court of appeal could have gone.
The rule of law or the black letter law
that can be inductively discerned
from the appellate court.
The rationale that the appellate court
used to decide the case.
And any particular dissents
or concurring opinions
that are not necessarily
the law of the case,
but at least go with it.
So a case brief, that's the
notes that you are taking
regarding the particular case,
regarding those details of the case.
It's a summary of the so called
important parts of the case.
And by the way, as a free bonus
you can download our
"Guide to Case Briefs"
and learn how to do them the
right way in the link below.
But, why do students do these summaries?
Well, there are three primary reasons.
The first is to learn how to read a case.
Standard thinking says that
the more cases you read
the more you will be able
to think like a lawyer.
And it's certainly true that in practice
you'll be reading lots and lots cases.
So it's a good idea to
understand what goes into a case,
why judges decide the way that they do,
and to be able to use
cases in your practice
as both a sword and shield
when you're litigating a particular idea.
The second reason is that you
need to prepare for finals.
So often you'll use cases on a final exam.
Obviously, most of what you
discuss in class is going to be
about the particular
cases that you're reading
because that's the case method itself.
And so it's not surprising
that you'll use a lot
of this information on a final exam.
And when your talking about
an issue spotter exam,
as you'll often get in law school,
then you can often use
the cases that you discuss
as analogies, as a way that the "court"
when it's your professor, should come out.
And if you don't take notes
on the cases that you read
and the discussion that you
have about the particular cases,
by the time that finals comes around
you'll probably have
forgotten all of your cases.
So it's good to have a written record
of what it was that you actually read.
And of course, there's the third reason
which is to prepare for class.
And frankly, if everyone is being honest
this is probably the number one reason.
You're compiling your notes so
that if the professor
calls on you, in class,
you're able to answer their questions
about the particular case.
This is the infamous
cold call in law school.
And it is the bane of most
law students' existence.
It's the Socratic Method
to pepper your students
with as many questions as possible
until they're simply unable to answer
any more questions about a given subject.
And the idea is that the more
you're questioned about something
the more you will learn what's
important and what's not.
And by the way, the funny thing is
that when class participation
doesn't count for anything
spedning all of this time
on preparing for class
instead of preparing for
finals can be a bad strategy.
But I get it, it's terrifying
to be called on by the professor in class,
so students are going to
err on the side of reading
their cases more carefully
than they might need to
and taking more copious
notes than they might need to
in order to have a
fruitful class discussion.
But here at Legal Eagle we think
that most case briefing that students do
is unnecessary and a waste of time.
Why?
Well, because you're going to be tested
using an issue spotting hypothetical.
And we have an entire video
on what an issue spotting hypo
or exam essay looks like.
You can check the link below.
But on an issue spotter,
you can't use 95% of the information
that you put in your case brief.
It's a waste of time.
Sure the professor might ask about
all of that information in class,
but the professor can't ask
that kind of information on the exam
and the test is what matters.
And I can't emphasize that enough.
I've seen hundreds of
issue spotting answers
and never once did they give points
for the procedural posture
of a particular case
or the history of the case
or even the rational or the case name.
An issue spotting exam, makes you pretend
that you're an attorney
and as in real life
you're rarely using that extra
information about a case.
What you are using is the
narrative story of the case
or the black letter law
that you'll find in a case.
You might apply just the
bare essential meaning
of what the law is, but ignore
all the rest of the story
or you might use the
facts of a particular case
to make an analogy to the issue,
or the hypo that's in the issue spotter
to make an argument one way or the other.
To say that this case is like the case
that you read before in
that the facts are similar
or that it should come out differently
because the facts are different.
But the thing is, the case
brief takes up so much time.
It takes up hundreds of hours
and you're focusing on
generally the wrong thing.
We think that instead of doing
the standard style of case briefing,
where you highlight your case brief
and make it look like a rainbow
with all the different
colors of the highlighter,
and write all of those different,
dozen things that you can write
about a particular case
in your case brief,
we think what you should do
what we call a three point brief.
A three point brief focuses
only on the three things
that your professor cares about.
And more importantly it's
the only three things
that you're actually going
to use on your final exam.
You can learn how to
write a three point brief
in our free "Guide to
Law School Case Briefs."
And the link to that is down below.
It will, I promise, save you hundreds,
if not thousands of hours
during your law school career.
And also check out our video on
"How to Study for Class using
the Flipped Case Method."
The link for that is also below.
It'll save you so much pain in
terms of reading your cases.
And also as always
please click on the like
and subscribe button if
you liked this video.
The more people subscribe, the more videos
we'll make on how to crush law school.
So what do you think about case briefs?
Did you come up with
a way of case briefing
that works for you?
Did you abandon them halfway
through the semester?
Or have you not started law school
and you're wondering just
what the hell a case brief is?
Let me know in the comments below.
And until next time at Legal Eagle
think like a lawyer and ace the exam.
Before we get into...
Law school in general
for a sec (laughs)...
Who wrote this crap...
Appellate...
After...
And after weighing...
Legal briefs to the...
Harder they do...